what we've come out noticing is that
we're super compatible Dylan
sprouting
[Music]
's longtime girlfriend quote they have
been showing off her ring to people and
are so happy hell yeah they're always
very in love with one another and by
each other's sides but they're even
happier than usual we just kind of look
at each other and we're like well I'm
really thankful yep et's learning to
love birds can't wait to start this new
time when we're gonna party a little bit
earlier this month the couple sparked
engagement rumors when the model had a
ring on that finger at the mammoth film
festival at the time Reps for the two
didn't confirm the speculation but a
source shared they seemed so happy and
comfortable together all weekend it's
nice yeah and that when they were
together it was clear they were very in
love
we make sure we Face Time once a day and
then we should text and just send a lot
of stupid names Dylan and Barbara's
romance started back in 2018 after he
slid into her DMs
in an interview with W magazine the star
admitted she didn't message me for six
months
and since the pairs bonded over their
love of anime we just like to hang out
inside eat chips anyway yeah so that was
the idea
a date night outside of her couch and
bed off the couch that's our favorite
character I think the the best part
that I've encountered so far is the
amount of anime that we've watched
despite their slow start Dylan's made it
clear he knows they're a perfect match
we know when to give each other space we
know when the other needs space
we've already divided labor around the
house in certain ways in the right uh
division right there's things we do in
the morning there's things we do at
night and so I I think our relationship
this is too much information is stronger
than ever
[Music]
foreign